Daniel is 28 years old he's a typical
European meat-eater that means that so
far in his life he has already eaten one
and a half cows 15 pigs and 300 chickens
no other food takes up as much land for
its production as meat the proportion of
climate damaging emissions created by
the meat and milk sector is huge the
manure it produces acidifies land and
oceans in short meets environmental
footprint is dismal that's a view shared
by Dutch biologist mark post in 2013 he
hit the headlines after going public
with the first artificially created
burger and it's better for the
environment and resources so that we can
produce much more meat in the USA Israel
in Japan biotechnologists are also
looking into growing meat out of a petri
dish posts first burger cost around 330
thousand US dollars to produce now
that's fallen to only 11 dollars but for
some a big problem is the nutrient
solution in which the meat grows in
order to have a nutrient solution for
the meat to grow in for the muscle
fibers to be able to grow you have to
develop a serum which you take from cow
fetuses from the blood of the fetus that
means you have to kill this cow kill the
fetus and then get the growth serum from
it in my opinion that's definitely also
a form of animal suffering sisters often
provide tea light and suseelan other
hopes for lab-grown meat have also since
been dashed in 2011 it was thought that
artificially created meat used around
55% of the energy needed for meat from a
real cow but in 2014 it turns out that
energy consumption for artificial meat
far from being less was in fact even
more
the editors of the new meat atlas don't
see lab-grown meat as a magic bullet
that will solve all of industrial meat
productions problems in vitro flies in
vitro meat is in our opinion a
distraction a token act here in our
Western countries
we must really urgent ly have our
consumption from 60 kilograms to 30
kilograms after Isaac he law and what
the report's authors are also calling
for that Germany stops flooding the
world with one of its exports cheap meat